American Electric Vehicle companies were
the biggest thing since sliced bread
just a couple years ago names like
Lordstown Motors Fisker and Nicola were
once hailed as the next big thing the
air apparent to Tesla and the companies
that were going to usher in the next
wave of the American Car well that
hasn't happened at all EV companies that
had valuations that rivaled American
Auto Giants forward and GM are now on
the verge of seeing their stock prices
go to zero I'm going to explain what's
happening to these highflying electric
vehicle companies why many of them on
the verge of insolvency and what this
means for the future of the American Car
let's get into it what's happening to
American EV companies Tesla has done
extraordinarily well it's the most
valuable car company in the world and
its stock is up more than 100% year-to
dat but the other EV companies have
fallen apart over the past year or so
one extreme example hydrogen electric
vehicle startup Nicola had a valuation
of nearly $29 billion in 2020 that made
it one of the most valuable car
companies in the US not anymore Nicholas
stock has fallen by around
95% and the company is worth around a
billion dollars today its stock has
never fully recovered from a short
sellers report filled with accusations
including against Bounder Trevor Milton
he was convicted of Fraud and recently
sentenced to 4 years in prison but
Nicola hasn't even been the worst
performing EV stock companies like
Lordstown Faraday Futures and protera
have all seen their stocks Fall by 99%
since going public short sellers who
make investments that company stock
prices will fall have piled in and
gotten paid Faraday Nicola and protera
have been the best performing short bets
in the automotive sector all year my
colleague George DS covers
transportation and he says making cars
is hard there is no simpler way I can
say that George what's going on in the
EV space so when a lot of these
companies went public in 2020 2021 many
Legacy automakers had yet to release
their kind of Flagship EV models so
production of Ford's F-150 Lightning
hadn't started yet these startups didn't
have any existing internal combustion
engine production lines that they needed
to maintain or pivot from so it seemed
that they could possibly bring an EV to
Market quicker and easier than some of
the Legacy car companies the problem is
whether you're a young startup or an old
automaker engineering is engineering
manufacturing is manufacturing and
Supply chains are Supply chains are no
real shortcuts and even Tesla's CEO Elon
Musk said that the company went through
manufacturing hell in 2017 Supply Chains
Got snared for pretty much every
automaker and startups struggle to get
the parts that they needed and every day
that you're not getting a vehicle off
the production line and selling it to
customers is a day that you're
potentially losing money but data show
Americans do want electric cars EV sales
continue to rise in the US and are
seeing exponential growth analytics firm
Cox Automotive estimates that around
300,000 electric vehicles were sold in
the third quarter making up around 8% of
all Auto Sales that's more than double
the number of sales and share seen in
the third quarter of 2021 and four times
the sales and Shar seen in the third
quarter of 2020 so what does the future
look like for electric vehicles a report
from our colleagues amth ramkumar and
Shane schifflet recently found that of
43 public electric vehicle companies
they studied 18 were on track to run out
of cash by the end of next year if they
didn't cut costs or raise new capital
and seven of those had just weeks of
cash on hand when contacted by the
Journal several companies said they
raised or are planning new financing and
are cutting costs so is it game over for
Ev companies here in the US I think what
you're seeing now is the hype starting
to fade away but reality setting in so
the companies that are in a stronger
position are the ones that have actually
managed to get their EVS into the hands
of paying customers but even the big
players are reassessing GM abandoned its
Target to build 400,000 EVS by 2024 and
Ford has pushed back its targets as our
latest wsj reports ing points out
there's still a bunch of companies
losing a lot of money so it's likely
there's going to be more
bloodshed